there are two types of pain the pain of
action and the pain of inaction the pain
of action is blunt in your face and
forces you to grow for every hour we
suffer through sharpening our skills
being proactive and restoring order we
don't reduce the amount of pain we face
but rather we take it on the chin we
sign up for it up front and because of
this voluntary acceptance day after day
we gain the strength to shoulder it by
embracing pain instead of running from
it we are simultaneously transformed by
it we become someone we are proud of
someone that others can depend upon
which in turn gives meaning to the pain
and it's this feeling of growth and
progress that helps us feel useful to
ourselves useful to others which gives
the suffering a purpose
[Music]
thank you
foreign